the path to the cemetery in jalalabad is
well trodden
these men are reflecting on the murder
of a young woman just hours earlier
she had been on the streets vaccinating
children against polio
now young men sweat over her soon-to-be
grave
but hers is not the only burial today
it was around 10 30 a.m and these female
vaccinators were with me when a few bad
guys arrived and killed them
we want the government to find and
punish the perpetrators
becerra samina and najina two volunteers
and a nurse
were working on the second day of a new
nationwide polio campaign
two were shot in one area of jalalabad
the third
in another area in a coordinated attack
amnesty international condemned the
killings
and recommended security measures be
increased for health workers
during the vaccination campaign
a vaccination worker was my cousin
unfortunately she was killed with two of
her colleagues today
she has been working as a vaccination
worker for a month to help support her
family
this is what they were doing walking
door to door administering an
oral polio vaccine to children
protection against the highly infectious
crippling and sometimes fatal disease
afghanistan reported 54 new cases of
polio last year
the highest on record since the taliban
fell in 2001.
it and pakistan are the only two
countries in the world where polio
remains endemic
many people particularly in taliban-held
areas oppose the polio vaccination drive
skepticism flourished after the cia used
a fake hepatitis vaccination campaign
in the hunt for osama bin laden
these female polio vaccination workers
were coming here as part of a
vaccination campaign
maybe they were followed because from
that side two gunmen attacked them
then they left the area afghanistan is
experiencing an
increase in targeted killings of
government employees civil society
members
activists and journalists there were 700
targeted killings just last year
in jalalabad earlier this month three
female journalists
none older than 20 were gunned down in
the street
on tuesday it was this street for two of
the women this was their last act
marking the wall to record children in
this house
had been vaccinated charlotte ballas al
jazeera